so a while ago I did a video of my condo
and my welcome tour and I hope got a
whole bunch of people who wrote in to
say Evan what's in your fringe we want
to see what's in your fridge so today's
a day you get to see what's in my fridge
we're going to take you on the tour so
you can see what's in there and I hope
there's some good stuff so I'm going to
switch to handheld mode here so we can
go on this tour this is my lunch well
what's left of it anyway it was broccoli
rice and fish pretty yummy this is a
little danger spot okay so we got the
minions guarding some sweets the cookies
are really good Nina meet these homemade
cookies that are super yummy but then
below our chocolates and candies and
lollipops that I try to stay away from
but they're tempting because they're
always right there in the county so here
we go let's open up the fridge and see
what's inside and hopefully it's not too
messy there we go inside the fridge so
we got some what rickards red beer we
got some stella some pop some i don't
know what this is aloe vera drink oh I
think that's Nina's there's a lot of
home cook stuff that Nina made these are
my lentils so every morning i have i
have lentils and some spinach on top and
that's how we start my day reading your
comments on YouTube we've got some okay
lips Nina meet these last night these
are amazing it's kale with oil and salt
on them we got some yummy leftover pasta
some green beans avocados I love carrots
are my snack of choice when i'm feeling
like munching during the day some fruits
and veggies I don't know what's in this
thing what is this looks milky I don't
see anything in there except okay
whatever we'll leave that sure Nina has
a plan for it so that's what's in the
fridge very exciting i'll give you the
bonus and we'll go in the freezer to
freezer
Oh bacon I love bacon I don't know about
you guys but I love bacon anytime I see
bacon I am happy we got bacon we got
shrimp we got some blueberries and I are
you supposed to eat frozen blueberries
as a healthy snack I just keep
forgetting to open up the freezer to get
the blueberries you see the paxil on
open maybe today will be the day and
then some bread and why do we have so
much bread look at this is like one two
three four five six seven eight things
of breads that are all segmented into
packs of four or five slices I don't
know what the idea is behind this but
I'm sure there's a method to this
madness so that's inside my freezer
that's inside my fridge you guys asked
for it so you got it let me know what
you think you like this video thumbs up
below you wanted to see anything else
here let me know and I'll make another
video thank you guys I'll see you soon